I have just a disgusting story that I
have to tell you about we've been
talking all week
about the shooting in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania at the Tree of Life
synagogue that left 11 people dead and
more people injured at the hands at the
barrel at the end of a barrel of an
extremist right-wing shooter and in
response there have been all sorts of
efforts made to reach out to the Jewish
community local Muslim communities in
Pittsburgh have raised significant
amounts of money to pay for the funerals
of the victims of the shooting in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania there's a
million dollar fundraiser which
yesterday was at seven hundred and fifty
thousand dollars for the victims of the
synagogue shooting I don't know exactly
where it is today
there have been vigils all over the
country I was just talking to some
friends earlier today who attended one
in Northampton Massachusetts yesterday
starting downtown at the old home of the
David Pakman show and ending at the
synagogue in Northampton Massachusetts
and similar events all over the country
I received emails from many people who
know that I am regularly targeted by
anti-semitic screeds and tirades and
just messages of support so Mike Pence
campaigning for Republicans decided he
was going to get in on the action
after this shooting took place at a
synagogue and since it's a week the week
before the midterm elections he decided
to invite one of the wackiest flavors of
rabbis and I hesitate to even really
call the guy a rabbi he's part of what's
called I call them Jews for Jesus I
think they're more properly known as
Messianic Jews and they are Jews who
unlike Jews believe that Jesus is the
Messiah and we could talk a lot about
Messianic Jews I've even appeared on the
programs there was there's this guy
called Michael Brown who has a very
homophobic right-wing radio show who has
interviewed me previously and he claims
to be Jewish and a Christian and a Jew
for Jesus and whatever I want to play
for you the first clip and to most of
you this ain't gon sound like any Jew
I've ever heard of before if you know
what I mean right this guy's called
Lauren Jacobs and here he is a
Jewish guy because there was a shooting
at a progressiva Galit Aryan synagogue
and this is the guy that they find
talking about Jesus God of Abraham god
of isaac god of jacob god and father of
my Lord and Savior Yeshua Jesus the
Messiah and my God and Father - you are
real and you know everything and you are
powerful and you are good and you are
able to hear and answer prayers please
hear and answer my prayers now Oh Lord
my god
your divinely inspired and true word
tells us unless you Lord build the house
the builders are wasting their efforts
they are building in vain a political
party is like those builders you might
notice it doesn't really sound like Jew
and instead of praying for the victims
of the synagogue attack he did pray for
the Republican candidates that are
running I prayed that you would enable
vice president Pence to continue to
fulfill his many employ and important
responsibilities with excellence I pray
for Attorney General Bill Schuette who's
running for governor for congressman
Mike Bishop who is running again for
Congress for Lena Epstein who was
running for Congress for John James who
was running for the Senate I pray for
them and for the Republican Party and
its candidates that they would honor you
and your ways that you might grant them
victory in this election this is a
message okay this is a way to kowtow to
the Jews and allies who are willing to
support Republicans without alienating
the extremist base which is often
anti-semitic you bring a Jew for Jesus
and to be very clear I don't care about
the religious views here okay I'm Jewish
by community I'm Jewish by culture I'm
Jewish by ethnicity I'm not religious
this is not about the believing of Jesus
to be the Messiah Jews are mostly
liberal in the United States in 2008 it
was he
high 70s or low 80s % voted for Obama
okay this is one of the most liberal
voting groups in the country the
synagogue that was shot up where eleven
people died and more were injured was a
progressive a gala terian synagogue to
say okay Jews were shot let's bring a
rabbi and bring this guy to pray for
Republican candidates is disgusting and
these people have no shame they are vile
disgusting and depraved and this is you
know Pat how we've been talking about
those signals it's another wink wink nod
nod moment that yeah we're with the
Jewish people because they got shot but
we're bringing a Republican Jew for
Jesus who has almost no shared traits
whatsoever with the majority of the
Jewish community in the United States
and it is a pandering attempt and it is
absolutely vile and as an now as a non
Jew Pat do you get why it's so
disgusting or is this does it just seem
like a Jews a Jew I don't know well I
wasn't familiar that there even are Jews
for Jesus I thought Jews for Jesus were
just Christians and that if you accept
Jesus as the Messiah then you're a
Christian so this is all very new to me
and it's astonishing how the Trump
people were able to mess this up it
seems like a slam dunk you just you just
invite some run-of-the-mill rabbi right
someone who's going to give a speech
that's a political and who in some ways
matches with the ideology of the people
at that synagogue who were shot up and
and they managed to mess it up it's it's
ridiculous yeah and I would actually
argue that they may not even see it as
messing it up I mean I think that they
did it deliberately and to make this
even worse the Messianic Jews are
denouncing this particular guy
apparently Lauren Jacobs was stripped of
his ordination by the Messianic Jewish
movement five years ago they got a fake
fake Jew you can't write this stuff and
I haven't said that for a while send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
but mixing it up a lot on Twitter lately
not sure if you've noticed also the
program is on twitter at david pakman
show follow us quick break big show for
you today today's show was made possible
in part by simple habit comm slash
Pakman at this point the benefits of
meditation have been pretty clearly
shown to be significant and that's why
I'm so excited that simple habit is
sponsoring the show which is a guided
meditation app that just won the 2018
Google Play award for best well-being
app I use the app myself all you need is
five to ten minutes a day simple habit
lets your brain go on a quick vacation
that it very likely really needs maybe
you've been thinking about giving
meditation a try you don't know where to
start simple habit is really the perfect
way to just jump right into it great for
beginners equally useful for people with
meditation experience they've got quick
meditations for first thing in the
morning for falling asleep at night for
clearing your mind when you're stressed
meditations for decision-making for
getting motivated getting focused
getting creative hundreds and hundreds
to choose from they're designed and
recorded by well-known names in the
world of meditation and mindfulness and
you can track all of your progress so
whatever time of day it is whatever mood
you're in there's probably a meditation
on simple habit that's perfectly suited
for whatever you're trying to accomplish
with meditation go check it out you can
try it free for seven days at simple
habit calm / Packman i've put a link
underneath this video